vom bauerngarten hier das problem k
extern 100 mehr als frauen hätten
offenbart bruder hinter sich aber nie
wie die la times
architektin seit genau 50 jahren
violations ist nicht nur ein beruf
sondern das ist ein lebensinhalt mal in
karow zu 19 82 als erste frau bei den
berliner philharmonikern aufgenommen hat
es liebt ihre baustellen ihr oberstes
gebot präzision außen und innen ganz
gleich ob sie ein altersheim erbaut ein
hotel umbaut oder ein historisches
geschäftsgebäude restauriert ich mein
halt immer noch was man im wettbewerb
ganze mal von zeigt das ebc ihnen kommt
ohne dass unser gott
1 in mainz urig ein studienplatz an der
eth 19 65 bedeutete das glück für die
bündnerin
der vater ist nicht begeistert
regierungsrat fonds riet er zur
handelsschule die tochter setzt sich
durch studiert als einige der wenigen
frauen direkt nach dem diplom wird sie
chefin ihre eigene mit 26
[Musik]
kommissionspräsident dafür sorge
präsident der finanzvorstand der bau
sekretär und also nun mängel und den
hacker präsident eröffnet york zu mir
sagt lächelnd
die junge dame ist sie bereits mutter
kohlschreiber
ich bin ziemlich erschrocken aber dem
aufrechnet wenn einer von denen her
ableite musikprojekt euro in allen
details stehen auch in der berliner
philharmonie gaben die männer den ton an
100 jahren
dann kommt die damals 26 jährige model
in karow zu ausziehen
sie spielt derart gut dass sie die
männer von uns bricht mein musikalisches
haus nach der ausbildung sucht die
violonistin eigentlich an der stelle in
der schweiz bewerbung als
konzertmeisterin beim zürcher
kammerorchester
die antwort hat es in sich das war
eigentlich eine der unglaublichsten
briefe die ich je bekommen habe und ich
habe mich beworben und bekam eine absage
weil ich eine frau bin
und sie wollten an den ersten pulten
lieber männer und das hat mich da
richtig seinerzeit schockiert
blöd für zügig gut für berlin
stardirigent herbert von karajan ist
beeindruckt von der jungen walliserin
[Musik]
das label star-architektin markt
theaters gar nicht so aber das label
haftet ihr an
spätestens seit sie für die fifa gebaut
hat und auch weil sie als frau in ihrer
liga immer noch eine exotin ist die
stars der architektur die marken der
branche sind besorge männer
warum eigentlich das pflicht der frauen
liegenschaft ein futter einziger wo in
architektur neue rolle spielt dass man
sich gesetzt das vielleicht abgeschwächt
mit kompromiss aber zu erreichen
und immer wieder einen weg findet dass
es auch funktioniert
das gibt aber kein markt
ein klang körper bestehend aus 108
männern und nur 20 frauen die parität
der geschlechter wird madeleine caruso
in ihrer aktiven zeit kaum mehr erleben
die frau im spitzenorchester bleibt ein
sonderfall
wenn man da ins orchester kommt ist man
für weil sie auf die subventionierung
bleibt man da und deswegen dauert also
wer wechseln weil es erst in den letzten
jahren vielleicht jetzt wirklich gleich
so viele frauen sich bewerben als männer
der geist des theaters in karlsruhe
könnte nicht weiter weg sein
wäre es nicht auch für die berliner
philharmoniker an der zeit sich mit der
frauenfrage zu beschäftigen
eine quote bis das verhältnis stimmt
ich bin für gleichberechtigung und
gleichberechtigung ist
gleichberechtigung von mann und frau
also ich werde also wenn man egal wenn
man jetzt jemanden bevorzugt ist es
nicht in ordnung für mich ich finde die
die qualität sollen entscheiden es
wichtig dass mit mir als frauen
wieso die kompetenz und die qualität
bringen und das mit positiven resultaten
knapper werdender paar junge kolleg in
der region die möglichkeit haben das
stimmt ich bin aber sicher wären will
der sich ihm sitzt die möglichkeit gut
perspektiven von frauen die es geschafft
haben erfolgreich sind in einer welt in
der vor allem männer die spielregeln
bestimmen netzwerke bilden definieren
was qualität bedeutet deshalb darf die
qualität nicht das einzige argument
bleiben